♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Corrections,"
week of July 12th.
I double-checked that
to make sure it was right,
because last time we did this,
I opened by saying,
"Welcome to 'Corrections,'
week of Monday, June 24th."
It was Thursday, June 24th.
And that is the fastest mistake
I've ever made
in a "Corrections."
I mean, that's embarrassing.
That's like if the minute
the Kentucky Derby started,
one of the horses exploded.
[ Light laughter ]
But we got it right.
Also, you might have noticed
from the title card,
this is now an Emmy-nominated
piece of television content.
That is not a joke.
It sounds like a joke.
It is not a joke.
And this is also not a joke,
and I mean it sincerely --
I could not have done this
without you.
We share this honor
because I think you know
that without you,
there's no "Corrections."
This was a team effort.
And I also want you to know
that if we should win,
all the rhetoric
about it being a team effort --
right out the window.
[ Laughter ]
It is mine, and mine alone,
and, oh, I'm gonna lord it
over you.
Oh, you'll be giving me
your corrections,
and I'll be like, "What?
Finland doesn't have mountains?
I can't hear you...
over my Emmy."
[ Light laughter ]
And if I lose, I will say
it was stolen.
I'm getting the whole --
I'm getting Sidney Powell,
Giuliani.
We will rain hell down
upon the Academy.
It is, uh --
It's Outstanding Short Form
Drama, Comedy, or Variety...
which I feel like
we tick all those boxes.
I feel like there's
a little of each in here.
As with a lot of "Corrections,"
we have to clean up stuff
from previous "Corrections."
We've talked a lot about
how -- or whether or not
roosters can blink or wink.
I'm just realizing
that maybe people who
had never watched "Corrections"
and are now tuning in
because it's Emmy nominated
are like, "Duh fuh?!"
But, yeah, no, roosters blinking
has been, like,
a multi-episode arc.
They have a membrane that wipes
the dust, like a clear membrane.
I called it
a "nictating" membrane.
It's "nictitating."
Nictitating.
And I cannot tell you --
You know,
sometimes there's one thing
that maybe one of you catches.
100 people
pointed out that I got it wrong.
And obviously --
I don't need to tell you --
I'd never heard of it,
and yet so many of you
know about chicken's eyes,
and this is a real shame-on-me.
But, like, I think
I've always kind of, like,
thought of our audience
as metropolitan and urban,
and you're farm people.
You know?
You're watching this.
You got, like, an iPhone
in one hand,
and you're just, like,
throwing -- The other hand's,
like, throwing seed
to your livestock.
And I worry about
your livestock...
because they live
with (bleep) jackals.
[ Light laughter ]
Bjork. This is -- Again, Bjork
has been famous for so long,
and I was told by a lot
of people I said it wrong.
And sometimes
when people tell me
how to say it,
it's not helpful
because I have to read
their pronunciation.
And so I found a video
of an Icelandic --
Icelandic, an Icelander --
I don't -- There's probably
a word, and...
I only wish we had
an infrastructure
where you could tell me
what that word was.
He said -- I watched the video
where he said --
I think it's close to this.
Byerk.
So I'm sure
that's not quite right,
but it's definitely not
"B-york."
And then we also said
when we mentioned it, that jork
was an Icelandic word
for joke about Bjork.
And then someone said, "Well,
if the "J" in "Bjork"
is silence -- silent,
it wouldn't be jork.
It would be "york."
Sure.
But you're being a "yerk."
[ Man laughs ]
The hardest part about this
is that, you know,
you got to read all the
comments. You got to mine
the comments
to find the corrections.
And sometimes you're
gonna find some people
who maybe just
don't like the show.
But there was an exchange that
I really greatly enjoyed,
which is someone --
And by the way,
I celebrate that this show
is not for everybody.
Someone wrote,
"This guy is so bad,
the audience doesn't want
to laugh at his jokes."
And then very kindly, someone
responded to that and said,
"He doesn't have an audience
at the moment."
And then the first person
wrote back,
"That's a sad excuse."
[ Laughter ]
Like, it might be --
It might be sad
that we don't have an audience,
but it's an airtight excuse
for why people aren't laughing.
"Why didn't Kevin come
to my birthday party?"
"He's dead."
"Okay."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
Can you imagine?
Look, I get that
maybe you think, like,
these jokes aren't funny.
Do you really think I'm doing it
for 180 people right now
and they're all just like, "Oh"?
[ Laughter ]
What? This -- This would be
the funniest show
in the world
to be watching right now
if there were 180 people.
I admit it's Monday.
We don't have audiences back
until the f--
On Monday, I'm gonna be like,
"We're so happy.
Our audience is back," and then
I'm just gonna do the show.
[ Laughs ]
What would the warm-up comedian
have to say?
Is it like
the bus from "Speed" rules?
Like, if we go under 50
or one of you makes a sound...
We've definitely learned if
we're gonna make a mistake,
don't make it in writing.
Like, I can sometimes make
a flub and get it through,
but if we make a mistake
in a graphic,
you guys go over it like
it's the Zapruder film.
Don't take the bait.
So we had a driver's license
of a cockroach.
And the birthday
was August 18, 2019,
and someone said, "Cockroaches
can't live longer than a year.
That cockroach would be dead."
And I'm not gonna argue
with the science of that.
Anybody who is bold enough
to write that in "Corrections"
obviously knows
what they're talking about
when it comes to
the life-span of cockroaches.
I do think they live longer
in New York.
You know? I had a...
This year in my kitchen,
I saw a cockroach
that was wearing a hat
that said, "Vote Dinkins."
[ Light laughter ]
We also -- Then we had another
driver's license of a cicada,
and someone pointed out
that the cicada's --
The height of the cicada
was 1'11",
and it weighed 2 ounces.
And they said,
"Why was the height in imperial
and the weight was in metric?"
And all I know is,
we're gonna find out,
and heads are gonna roll,
because that's one of
the hard, fast rules here --
not to mix those up.
We had a...
a key photo of me getting
an appendectomy.
Can we look at that real quick?
[ Laughter ]
Again, so many people said
that's definitely not where
that incision would be.
I'd say we got, like, 100
of those.
And then one guy said,
"CDC rules.
You'd be wearing a mask."
All right, we talked about --
We said Alice Cooper...
...bit the head off a chicken.
And someone
came at us pretty hard
and said we had conflated
two things.
Ozzy Osbourne
bit the head off a bat.
Alice Cooper threw a chicken
into the crowd,
and the crowd
tore the chicken apart.
And once again,
I'm fairly confident
that was written by a stepdad.
[ Light laughter ]
"Alice Cooper bit
the head off a chicken."
"Uh, guys,
that is absolutely not the case.
Dave, get out of here!
Just don't want you
to embarrass yourself.
You're embarrassing me in
front of my friends right now!
Ozzy bit the head off a bat.
Ozzy's got to live that down.
Cooper didn't, man.
Cooper threw a chicken
into the crowd,
they tore it apart.
That's all that happened."
Why do I care?
"'Cause you're gonna get sued
for libel if Alice Cooper
hears you saying that.
It's slander if you say it.
"You seen
the new 'Modern Drummer'?
[ Laughter ]
Leiderman's on the cover.
Pretty cool."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
"It was a big deal, dude."
[ Laughter ]
We said that the C.E.O. of
Subway stands behind his tuna,
and then we said
he stays downwind.
We should have said upwind.
We heard that a lot.
You know, the premise
being you wouldn't --
you wouldn't want to smell it.
Ooh, we said that --
I guess fish now can get
addicted to stuff
in the water like crystal meth,
and then we showed a picture
of a shark with no teeth.
And then I said --
It wasn't written,
but I said, "Oh, I know.
A shark's not a fish,"
worried that I would be
corrected
because that's how in my head
you have me.
And then a lot of you said,
"No, a shark is a fish."
But you -- Yeah, but
you could hear yourselves
saying that, though, right?
But then this.
I wanted to print this out
and get this exactly right,
because this is something
somebody wrote
about this question about,
is a shark a fish?
It said,
"Not a correction per se,
but a fun fact about fish.
Fish are not a taxonomic group
the way vertebrates or mammals
are because the group
does not include
all the descendants
of a common ancestor.
If it did, all reptiles,
amphibians, birds, and mammals
would also be considered fish
because all are descended
from an ancient lobe-finned fish
called Sarcopterygii.
Fish is just
a term of convenience
to refer to a diverse group
of swimming aquatic organisms."
And not to correct a corrector,
but I...
don't think that's a fun fact.
[ Laughter ]
We talked this week about how...
Monday was the 20th anniversary
of when myself and Amy Poehler
auditioned to be on "SNL,"
and so it is now --
I'm coming up on 20 years
in the building,
which is -- which is surreal.
I have the same I.D.
It is...
I am a baby.
When you look at my first I.D.,
just, I'm a kid.
[ Laughter ]
First --
The first thing Loren said
is, "We're gonna
get your teeth fixed."
This is --
This is really exciting.
We have a prop budget now.
We got Emmy nominated,
and they said,
"You can do props
in 'Corrections.'"
I said,
"We have a props budget?"
They said, "Prop."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Can I keep this?"
And they're like, "No."
I've got to give it back.
And I'm like, "What?"
They said,
"We're gonna melt it down."
Last night -- So 20 years ago,
I met Mike Shoemaker,
and obviously we've talked
a lot about our friendship.
And last night
he and I went out to dinner
and had a very nice night
talking about
how lucky we've been, and...
...I make fun of Mike.
I'm not gonna do the voice today
because,
you know, the category we're
nominated for is also drama.
And we -- Mike Shoemaker
is the gateway
to everything good
I have known in show business.
And we rewarded ourselves
last night.
We don't usually go out
to fancy dinners,
but we went
to Eleven Madison Park.
It was a very fancy,
incredible meal.
And when it was over, he said,
"Why do you think I --"
because he had suggested it.
"Why do you think I wanted
to go to Eleven Madison Park?"
And I said, "I don't know."
He goes, "The eleven's
the important thing."
And I said, "Is it because...
...our friendship is an 11
out of 10?"
And he said no, and then
he just slowly did this.
[ Laughter ]
And just, like, held it there
a really long time.
Drama, comedy, variety.
All right, you guys.
Well,
I think we've done it again,
and we will be back next week.
This was "Corrections."